en los vídeos pasados hemos estudiado en
qué casos se conservan los ángulos y los
lados al aplicar una transformación esta
vez vamos a pensar en lo que se
conservan al aplicar una secuencia de
transformaciones en particular nos
interesa saber qué es lo que le pasa a
la medida de los ángulos déjame
escribirlo qué es lo que le pasa a la
medida de los ángulos ya la longitud de
los lados déjame escribirlo a la
longitud de los lados si aplicamos una
secuencia de transformaciones a
cualquier figura no veamos este primer
ejemplo a continuación se describe una
secuencia de transformaciones primero
vamos a aplicar una traslación después
una reflexión sobre la recta horizontal
pq y por último un estiramiento vertical
sobre pq
esta secuencia conservará la medida de
los ángulos
esta secuencia conservará la longitud de
los lados bueno primero obtengo una
traslación y para nuestra suerte la
traslación es una transformación rígida
por lo tanto conservará ambas la medida
de los ángulos y la longitud de los
lados así que estas y después seguimos
con una reflexión sobre la recta
horizontal pq para nuestra suerte
una reflexión también es una
transformación digital por lo tanto
seguiremos conservando la medida de los
ángulos y la longitud de los lados por
último un estiramiento vertical sobre pq
bueno pensemos un poco en qué hace un
estiramiento vertical
si tuviera un triángulo por aquí ok
vamos a trazar lo correctamente
ok este va a ser mi triángulo y déjame
ponerle nombre supongamos que es el
triángulo
ve
y ahora voy a hacer un estiramiento
vertical del vértice y del vértice b así
que voy a estirar hacia arriba
estos dos vértices ok de tal manera que
aquí tengo a mi nuevo punto a prima ok y
que por acá tengo a mi nuevo punto de
prima ok ahora observan este nuevo
triángulo observa cómo se va uniendo
este nuevo triángulo y cómo están
cambiando las cosas en definitiva este
ángulo se está cambiando ahora es un
nuevo ángulo cm y también puedes ver que
los lados
por ejemplo el lado hace es distinto al
lado a prima se prima por lo tanto la
longitud de la prima se prima es
distinta a la longitud de ac así que en
este caso cuando tenemos un estiramiento
vertical
si hablamos de estirar la figura
claramente no se conservan ni los
ángulos ni las longitudes de gm
en este caso nada se conserva de manera
general si estás trabajando con una
transformación rígida al aplicarla se
conservan la medida de los ángulos y la
longitud de los lados si aplicas un
estiramiento nada se conserva bien
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora voy a traer
este de por acá
a continuación se describe una secuencia
de transformaciones y me dan tres
transformaciones pausa el vídeo y piensa
si se conservan la medida de los ángulos
y la longitud de los lados bien primero
tenemos una rotación alrededor del punto
p la rotación es una transformación
rígida por lo tanto en este caso se
conserva la medida de los ángulos y la
longitud de los lados así que si una
traslación como dijimos también es una
transformación rígida de modo que se
conservan la medida de los ángulos y la
longitud de los lados y por último
tenemos otra rotación alrededor del
punto p bueno la rotación es una
transformación rígida
se conservan la medida de los ángulos y
la longitud de los lados y ahora sí
puedo concluir que en este escenario se
conserva todo dejan escribir lo tanto la
medida de los ángulos como la longitud
de los lados muy bien hagamos uno más
a continuación se describen una
secuencia de transformación es una
potencia cuyo centro es el punto p una
rotación alrededor del punto cum y una
reflexión sobre la recta horizontal p
pausa el vídeo de nuevo y piensa si se
conserva la medida de los ángulos y la
longitud de los lados bien la primera
transformación es una potencia cuyo
centro es el punto p lado motes ya es
una transformación no rígida por lo
tanto la longitud de los lados no se
conserva déjame escribirlo pero en una
potencia y esto lo hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores los ángulos si se conservan
así que también voy a escribirlo
los ángulos si se conservan hasta ahora
sólo hemos perdido la longitud de los
lados pero seguimos conservando la
medida de los ángulos después tengo una
rotación alrededor del punto com bueno
esta es una transformación rígida así
que conservamos lo que todavía nos queda
es decir seguimos conservando la medida
del 2
y por último tengo una reflexión sobre
la recta horizontal pq bueno una
reflexión también es una transformación
rígida por lo que conservaremos la
medida de los ángulos ya no la longitud
de los lados porque la perdimos en la
potencia recuerda que las
transformaciones rígidas también
conservan la longitud de los lados pero
como la primera transformación no
conservamos esta longitud de los lados
entonces no conservaremos las longitudes
iniciales por lo tanto toda esta
secuencia de transformaciones sólo
conservan los ángulos y ya hemos
terminado hasta la próxima